i have an email here
for this week's episode of ask mr
wonderful uh
rather interesting i think it's going to
take us on quite a journey
from yasmina yes mina
hi mr wonderful i'm a huge shark tank
fan i've been watching the show for
eight years
i've just graduated and i'm off to
college
and i think my first term is going to be
a virtual one
from my parents basement well
yes mina that is the sign of the times
there's no question about it
she goes on to say my plan is to become
an
entrepreneur don't know what yet
or which business sector yeah i get that
life is
life is like a box of chocolates you
don't know when you're just going to
school what's going to happen next
yes mina so i get that then she says
i don't think you've ever said on shark
tank
how you made your first million dollars
can i be the one to ask you that
what can i learn from that experience
i understand if you don't want to answer
but i would really like to know
okay yes meena you're right i never have
talked about that and maybe there are
some interesting lessons to be learned
there
it's sort of like the journey you're
starting now in some ways and maybe
tell you about some of the mistakes i
made which would be in some ways more
valuable
than just talking about success because
i wouldn't want you to make those again
and i actually feel that way about any
entrepreneur
that's had success that they would pass
forward
a path of least resistance so to speak
maybe give you some ideas on what not to
do
here it is let's pick it up where you
are i'm off to college so i tell my
stepfather
i really want to be a photographer or a
rock star and he says you're nuts you'll
starve to death doing that
it's very very hard and it's very
competitive and those are
you know very binary outcomes because
either you're a really really good
photographer which i'm not sure you are
to stay competitive in the commercial
world
and frankly i've heard your guitar and
you got a long way to go
well at least he was telling me the
truth at the time but the point is
college is where i went and and i
decided even back then i thought well
maybe i should try
being an engineer because those guys
seem to get jobs i don't know what i
want to do so i enrolled in engineering
engineering 101
also some psych classes because i wanted
to meet some girls
and at the time a very new cohort called
environmental studies no one had ever
heard of it at the time
anyways i go to my first class of
engineering
whoa was that tough whoa whoa whoa whoa
and i i wanted to party and i mean look
i'm just telling you the truth
so i didn't hang out in engineering too
long and i spent my
four years in psychology um
and in in environmental studies in
third year i meet this girl and we uh
you know it's my first serious
relationship
and we move in together and she was
rather artsy
and she convinced me to go to night
class in cinematography
advanced cinematography you know i was
into photography but i'd never
worked with film before there was some
complex technology it's not what it is
today but
it it was tough and i really got into it
i was you know we were we're in we'd go
three hours these night classes and then
we'd film and then we'd edit and we'd
talk about making film and i was falling
in love but i was also falling in love
with cinematography
and the potential of what it could be
and being a filmmaker
kind of went into that artistic bent but
boy that is not a place to to make money
easily
um but but here's what happens uh as i
get into the film community
i start meeting people that say look you
know we've seen some of your camera work
uh can we hire you as a cameraman we're
doing an industrial shoot
or we're doing this we're doing that
doing some sports filming whatever
we just need camera guys i'm learning
the tools of the trade i'm learning how
to be a cameraman i'm learning how to
buy film i'm learning how to budget for
a shoot industrial commercial you name
it i'm a sound guy
i'm a lighting guy i mean when you're
that small you're doing everything and
i'm just
i was just learning how to do it and
really loving it and working a lot you
know going to school all day and then
shooting all night editing on weekends
when you're really
passionate about something it's
fantastic if you can merge that into
your work because
you don't mind working 25 hours a day
and believe me i was
it was it was incredible eventually i
had an eight plate steam back which is
an editing machine
right where we lived and i was cutting
film and processing and
and mixing sound and you name it and
then finishing off my degree so i
graduate
i get great marks in in in psychology
environmental studies i go home
and my dad says to me well how are you
going to get a job with this
the environmental stuff hadn't even
happened yet and psychology
tough you know unless you want to get
into research you want to go do your phd
not so easy he was right he's always
right and so he said why don't you
go get a business degree i know you
still want to be a filmmaker and you
want to
be a musician and all this stuff and a
photographer but why don't you get some
tools some building blocks
about business because really even if
you pursue any of those
you know disciplines you're still going
to need some basic business so you can
run your life
so i applied i got in this is where the
serendipitous nature of life the box of
chocolate starts to happen
i'm sitting down with the dean after i
get accepted of the business school and
i say to him dean
listen um i'm going to spend 24 months
here getting this degree
and i bet you you have an ongoing need
to recruit people from all around the
world
why don't you let me make a film about
this experience i'm a filmmaker
um i want to pursue a business degree
but i know how to make films and
i could hire a crew i could document
this whole experience from the day
everybody meet each other right through
the learning in the class
what they're experiencing is as the time
goes on and and
get you the inside story of what it's
like
to pursue you know a business degree in
such an intense program because
mbas are tough like you burn a lot of
hours you work every day of the week
and he said let me take it up with with
a few of the faculty see if i can get
you know people to i'll raise the flag
see if anybody's interested
and i said one other thing it's going to
cost about 50 grand and so
i have to hire people to where i have to
i get lights i gotta get camera guys
sound guys
i gotta edit the thing i gotta rent
equipment here she said
let's wait on the budget let me just
find out if anybody's interested two
days later and when i'm just starting
the program he says
there's a lot of interest but you're
gonna do it for thirty thousand i said
done one of those deals and that was the
beginning of a really
remarkable experience because i also
said to him dean
i can't do the full program and shoot a
film for two years
you got to cut me some slack give me a
couple of credits on this and mark the
film based on its merits
and what others say about it and how it
is for you as a tool to recruit
so if it's really a crappy tool then i
should get a very low mark
and if it's a really good film you
should score it
highly just like any other class in my
participation
we did that deal and i went to work and
i shot that film
and it it was a crazy experience
but when it was over 24 months later the
film was a unique insight into what the
program was about in a way
no other person could have done it it's
tough
anything worthwhile is tough i think
that if it wasn't tough our students
and our alumni wouldn't be very happy
because it would have been a wasted
couple of years
the big thing that you acquire as the
year progresses
is the ability to uh
determine what the key issues are and
what's extraneous to the
the problem it was a fantastic tool
for for recruiting they showed it to
everybody that's going to come to that
school and
send it all around the world i got a
huge score in it
and i graduated like top of my class or
right up there i can't remember what the
deal was but i did well
now having shot that film i'd hired a
crew
and i said guys why don't we form a
company together
we're really good at this let's form a
company
and there was a guy named dave thomas
who's an incredible writer went on to do
stuff in sports television
works with neil young now all kinds of
interesting stuff he's a great
documentary maker
and producer and just thinks in a
different way
and another guy named scott mckenzie who
was you know more focused on the actual
production
and and i and i was into the you know i
wanted to use my business tools and i
wanted to
budget and i wanted to do stuff and be a
cameraman and and then
we were really good at it was called
special events television and the way we
created value in television to create
value you have to create a unique
format like friends the show you've
heard of that's a format
somebody owns that format nobody else
can make friends because they own the
format
we went into sports television we
created sports formats bobby orr and the
hockey legends
was one of them we we had a huge sponsor
one of the food companies
we did a show called the original six
where we got retired hockey stars from
the original six teams
detroit boston you know etcetera new
york they played each other
and it was wildly successful we made
television out of it
and then we had a gold mine hit don
cherry's grapevine remember don cherry
that eclectic coach with bobby orr in
boston
he was fantastic on television he had a
dog that he brought on he was a great
interviewer
the format caught on fire
the company took off we were selling the
shows each week we were broadcasting
them everywhere
and i looked at my partners and i said
wow look at this
no longer it was i think it was only two
years later
we got bought out it was my first
transaction
and i went this is good this was an
incredible experience we started with
nothing and we created this company it
was worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars each
towards the end i had enrolled in a
night class
with a computer called an osborne
computer it was the first portable
computer ever made it was a cpm
operating system
and i met this guy named john freeman
john had designed
a program that drove hewlett-packard
plotters now when you're in television
you're always making all these graphics
it's very expensive very time consuming
titles we'd have to get them printed and
there wasn't any you know digitized
technology at that point
but john learned how to take a a
multi-pin hewlett-packard plotter which
was an
x-y axis pen driven by a computer and do
graphics
for a giant oil company he worked with
he was an executive there and he showed
it to me at the
you know and this is right after we'd
sold
special in television and i looked at it
and said john
every guy that buys a plotter from
hewlett-packard is going to want one of
these
software packages let's form
a partnership and i'll market this stuff
and you'll write the code and i will fly
all around the world and convince the
plotter companies to bundle that
software
with their plotters he said well
but i can't give up my job i got a
family out of kids i said look you write
code all night and weekends
i don't have a job i just sold my
company and i remember sitting on the
red chair in my living room
we were trying to name the company and
we called it
soft key s-o-f-t-k-e-y
soft key software products john and i
that was the beginning of a journey
john writes the code we packaged it up
our first product was called
key chart every product we made had the
key in front of it
because we really grew the business but
i i flew down to san diego where
a woman named mary zoller was running
the plotter division and i put on a show
i said mary you've got to bundle this
i'll do it for 12
a unit she just laughed at me
at least she was honest she said kevin
i'm the number one plotter on earth
everybody writes code for me what do i
need you for maybe you should talk to
some of my competitors and it was one of
those
you know how your phone makes that bing
when a message comes in
and that's exactly what i did all the
japanese all the german everybody
else that was trying to compete with
hewlett-packard the number one plotter
i said what if you bundled my software
with it and
you got free software maybe that's a
competitive edge
and boy did that work we sold
millions of copies of key chart millions
bundled with
all these different plotters that were
on the market
and in the end i think we're only
getting 12 cents a copy but we were
making a ton of money
and we just kept going and going and
going
now here's i think when my first million
comes in
i started getting calls from everybody
because it was the beginning of the dot
com era
and they wanted to invest in my company
and i called up john said john
what do you want to do buddy and he said
look i'm just happy with graphics
you know you want to make this thing
huge
why don't you buy me out and you go on
your journey i said
i'm cool with it john i think john's
pretty happy guy
because he took some cash he took some
stock
and i'm cool with that too he was he was
a founder of softkey software products
and we just kept going we did dozens of
products we went to a trade show called
comdex and we just got bigger and bigger
a bunch of private equity guys invested
in it
and then one day um a banker came to me
and said why don't we take softkey
software products public
i said why'd you work with the finance
guys put a deal together and i'm happy
to take it public now i'll never
remember the morning we went to the
exchange
i woke up in the morning and i
looked at myself in the mirror and i i
saw the stock was trading from the night
before and i looked at the stock price
the number of shares i had and he went
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] rich
it never hit me
until then and when i talked to
entrepreneurs today
it's always the same they always say the
same thing they say i didn't think about
the money
my point is it was never about the money
when i talked to entrepreneurs today
that had the same experience from like
their basement to
to that huge liquidity event they don't
even think about it
it's the journey it's the passion for
the business
that's what got them going that's what
got me going
that was my first million dollars
it was way more than a million but the
whole point it was binary
it was like zero and then a lot
this whole entrepreneurial journey most
people i talk to
they have this unique moment in their
lives
when this happens and for me it was when
i was in grade 11 in high school
and i got my first job and
and i when i teach these days i always
tell this story but i'll tell it to you
now
i wanted that job because the girl i was
interested in in high school was working
at the shoe store across the mall and
this was an ice cream store and they
were looking for a scooper
and so i took the job and the first day
i was there
the owner was a woman said to me you
know when you give the little samples
out of ice cream on little sticks people
take their gum out and they throw it on
the floor and this this store had
mexican tiles beautiful tiles
and the gum was you know got stuck on
them and it turned dark it looked ugly
day was over you know i shut all the ice
cream bins down
and i was ready to get back on my bike
go home and she said to me
um scrape the gum off the floor
you can't lay before you scrape the gum
off the floor and i said well
and i knew that this girl was watching
me from across the mall because if we're
going to check out and you know go get
a soda or something together i was
really looking forward to it and i said
to the owner i can't
he hired me as a scooper i'm not a
scraper i'm not going to get down on my
knees because i didn't want a
girl across the hall to see me on my
knees scraping gum and she said
no you're an employee you're going to do
exactly
what i say this is magoo's ice cream
parlor this was magoo's ice cream parlor
was right here the counter was right
here and she said you're
fired get out of my ice cream store but
within minutes i was on my bicycle on my
way home in utter shame in shock that
she had that kind of control
over my life changed my life forever i
have never
ever in my life worked for someone again
ever
no one has ever had control over me ever
and never will
and that's when that's another one of
those moments where the lights go off
and i realized in life there's
two types of people there's the people
that own the store
and there's the people that scrape the
[ __ ] off the floor
and you kind of have to decide which one
do you want to be
and i'm not dissing being an employee
there's nothing wrong with that that's a
different life
if you want that security that's cool
and you can be a great employee and i've
talked about that before but
i didn't want to be an employee i didn't
want someone to have that kind of power
over me i never wanted that
ever again and and she was the reason
i owe her so much that she
twisted me that day to and i never had a
job
i never had a full-time job again in my
life
i only worked for myself from that day
on that was the beginning of my
entrepreneurial journey
so yasmina if you have found that you
know i'm answering your question
you have to have that catharsis you have
to make that decision you're going to
take that path from entrepreneurship
and it's not for everybody but if it's
in you you'll know
so i say to every entrepreneur that's
starting their journey or contemplating
it
do not go after entrepreneurship out of
the greed of money
you will never find it it's a passion
for personal freedom and the only way
you're going to make your first million
dollars
and this is a material challenge
is you have to solve a problem for
somebody
and if you solve that problem for one
person and it's a similar problem that
millions of other people have that's the
core of what a business is
entrepreneurs see problems find
solutions and that's how they create a
business
businesses are always solving problems
for people
so your first job if you're pursuing
your first million and i've said this
many times it's not easy to make a
million
dollars i've said it's virtually you
know
the most difficult task on earth because
you're basically starting a business and
it doesn't happen overnight
and then the first five million is next
to impossible and the strange thing but
maybe
you know intuitively makes sense is
building wealth past that
is about investing it's about you know
you make your first million as an
operator and then you become an investor
now today i am an investor
and i must say that i've learned a lot
on the road you know just
the journey i've had i've had a chance
to be pitched ideas from thousands of
people
thousands and i have learned something
to be true there are three
elements that are involved in every
single presentation that's successful
in getting finance and if you're an
entrepreneur you're trying to make your
first million
usually you need to raise capital
somewhere even if it's some friends and
family so i want you to listen to this
advice because
these attributes aren't found some of
the time they're found all the time
and it's really about communications
that's what it is it's about
communicating the opportunity and making
people understand it because
if if you can't explain where you want
to go
no one will follow you so
i recently had the opportunity to talk
to the students at mendoza at notre dame
about this and i want you to listen to
what i said because
i i think it kind of summarizes a very
important
step and remember it doesn't determine
the outcome of the business this is just
trying to raise capital to get started
which sometimes is the hardest part i
have a thesis
i'll tell you what it is what are you
watching when you watch shark tank
you're watching the pursuit of freedom
is there anything more noble than
creating your own wealth and setting
yourself free
no that's what shark tank's about
it's the essence of personal freedom
it's not about getting rich
it's about achieving something for
yourself that is unique to our society
and capitalism personal freedom
and that's why i'm here today i want to
talk to you about that
that's what matters that's what creates
everything that's great in america
is the ability to start a business from
scratch in your basement whether it's a
cupcake or a group book or
thousands of other ideas create a
business worth millions of dollars
employ hundreds of people
provide for your family yourself their
families
and all the good things we enjoy
from capitalism which is freedom
now there's a lot of sacrifice involved
i'm speaking to those of you in this
room
that want to become entrepreneurs so
let's try and learn
something from the shark tank experience
i want to share with you other than
funny pictures like this
three common attributes to
all of the deals that got funded on
shark tank versus all the ones that
didn't this does not speak to the
outcome of the businesses
it speaks to those entrepreneurs that
are able to sit in front of investors or
stand there and actually get their money
and i want you to realize that there's a
huge opportunity to understand something
unique here
because in each of these three cases
they were present in one
hundred percent of the deals that got
funded
over thousands of presentations
but in every case these three attributes
were there
and why i'm bringing it up now is i know
some people are going to be up in front
of me in just a few minutes
and i want them to hear what i'm saying
here because maybe they want to modify
their presentations a little bit
all right number one in one hundred
percent of the cases
the deals that got funded the
entrepreneur was able to articulate the
vision
in 90 seconds or less the idea was so
blindingly simple that you could
understand it
in a minute this is a cupcake we put it
in a jar we ship it to people for 6.95
i get it this is a groove book i carved
a groove in it so i can ship it
at the price of a magazine i get it
see what i'm saying all right 100
of the cases 90 seconds or less number
two
in every case the entrepreneur usually a
team or 80
of the time were able to articulate why
they were the right people
to execute the business plan what
credentials what confidence what
experience
why were they able to take an idea and
turn it into a business
very important present
in 100 of the deals that got financed
now this is far more sinister this last
point
because in front of me multiple times i
have seen
deals that are now like an isotope
sizzling the first two are present
sharks are fighting everybody wants in
and then this happens
in one hundred percent of the time the
people got financed they were able to
answer
every single question about their
business model
and their numbers with perfection
when you're sitting listening to an
entrepreneur and you start to ask them
how much market share do you need to
break even what's your margins
how large is the market how fast is it
growing who's your number one
competition
how much free cash flow you think you'll
make in the first three years
if you can't answer those questions
or you make a mistake or you seem lost
you're screwed
this is really important this last one's
a killer
and i want you to remember that because
i tell entrepreneurs today if you're not
good with numbers
bring someone who is it's incredibly
important
if anybody ever asks me about mendoza
i'm going to say the
wine is excellent
anyways thank you i had a great time and
go irish